we've seen that from Marx in the first
part of the Communist Manifesto the
bourgeoisie is the revolutionary class
that sweeps away the entire old world
and produces a new social world in which
human beings live in industrial society
and the main class conflict ends up
being one of the proletariat versus the
bourgeoisie because the the proletariat
is brought into existence and as such by
the processes that the bourgeoisie uses
in order to attain its dominance over
the earlier classes it within society
now Marx and Engels think that the
bourgeoisie in creating the proletariat
in creating the conditions on which they
live in and not fixing them along the
way and they don't they don't think that
the border is you could actually fix
that anyway have generated their own as
they call them gravediggers so the idea
is that something is going to happen but
it's not going to happen right away as a
matter of fact the Communist Party that
this is the manifesto for it is engaged
in in this long generation after
generation process of trying to increase
what they call class consciousness and
to chart out and make clear for the
proletariat what has been happening to
them now
one thing I do want to point out before
we go into this that Marx thinks is and
Marx and Engels think is really a major
contribution made by bourgeois society
and especially the Industrial modes of
production is that what they've done is
they've peeled off the masks
they've unveiled the relations that
really exist between human beings the
things that are the most determinative
so you know the earlier modes of
interaction which were guided by say
courtesy or privilege for the No
those are taken away and what
substituted for them is what he calls
the cash you know or value Nexus people
are evaluated in terms of what can they
actually provide what can they
contribute it with property what income
do they have what prospects what can
they produce for for one or for society
now there's a number of conditions that
are going to gradually change the
condition of the proletariat and and
turn them into a very large and a very
dangerous class so we want to look at
what's going on
in all of this so a sort of
centralization a sort of standardization
of society is going to go on and what
else is going to happen in industrial
society I mean think about how far this
has gone along today there's increasing
use of machines so if we think about
weaving you know what's required in
order to produce modern clothing
originally you had people working in
textile mills and they would take for
example cotton cotton would come from
various places including Egypt also the
you know the United States eventually
and the cotton would be turned into fat
will turned into thread first and then
the thread had to be woven and they had
as latticework this immense machines for
weaving it this for example this isn't
cotton I don't think but but it's woven
you can see the the fabric there the
weave then you know there would be other
processes down the line seamstresses
would would cut the cloth up and make it
into clothing then you have somebody
who'd sell the clothing wholesale and
eventually gets the retailer's and then
the person buys it wears it these
incredible processes now think about
what it's like today how far industrial
manufacturing is gone we've introduced
way more machines so if there is a
proletariat today they'd be in a even
more mechanized alienated
according to Marx wouldn't they we have
machines that can actually make machines
or run other machines we have managed to
mechanize and thereby standardize the
processes as he says you know what
happens is the the people who are
engaged in these sort of sort of work
cease to enjoy their work they cease to
identify with it there we go
owing to the extensive use of machinery
and the division of labor the work of
the proletarians has lost all individual
character you know think for example
when you're writing a report in say this
class I said tell me what Marx is saying
here there's still something of you
involved in it it's you that's being
graded it's your writing now imagine
that you were part of a paper mill and
when I say paper mill I don't mean what
you know the old fashioned paper mills
that generate reams of paper I mean
these places where you can buy term
papers from where the people just churn
them out and turn them out and turn them
out when you're doing that sort of thing
it's kind of alienating it no longer
feels like it's your work because it's
not your work you're selling it to
somebody else and they present it as
their own so he says it's lost all charm
for the workman he becomes an appendage
of the Machine and it is only the most
simple most monotonous and most easily
acquired knack that is required of him
so what's going on there there's there's
a lack of what we nowadays call job
satisfaction and this is the case isn't
it for a lot of the work that we do
because I worked a lot of jobs where I
wasn't particularly happy with what I
was doing and I felt that my talents
weren't being adequately used but I
needed the money and that's the
situation of the proletariat area the
more that you do those kind of jobs over
and over and over again the more your
horizons begin to shrink to where you
say well maybe I am just this maybe this
is all there is for me the reduction of
the person to the labor that they
provide that's the only value that the
proletariat's are given socially what
they can actually provide what they can
get paid for doing this leads us to
talking about the exploitation of
surplus value this is a central Marxist
concept so he he talks about this by
saying the cost of production of a work
person the workman is restricted almost
entirely to the means of substance that
he requires for maintenance and for the
propagation of the race now what does
that mean and why would that be the case
what we're saying there is that all you
actually need to pay a work person is
enough so that he can feed himself and
whoever else is dependent upon him and
provide even is enough to have a house
he can have an apartment if he if he
needs a car to get to work enough that
he can actually have a car and insurance
and you know we can multiply these sorts
of things the basic idea is that there's
some sort of minimum wage and that
minimum wage is not set by a government
for example but is set by saying what is
the minimum that I need to pay this guy
to get him to show up to work and do the
work that I want so that I have the
product now where is the rest of the the
money go well that's what we call
surplus value I'll use an example from
when I used to work in a pizza
restaurant so a back then minimum wage
was 335 an hour and I started out at
minimum wage and I would make pizzas at
this pizza restaurant and I probably
could make you know and bake at least
say 20 pizzas an hour each pizza sold
for more than 335 each pizza sold for 5
or 6 bucks now you could say well
there's the cost of you know raw
materials and and you know there's the
the building and all that sort of stuff
that's true you know the person who is
out laying the expense for for providing
the basic materials the tools the
location
who's built up goodwill among customers
there is something there right Marx is
perfectly fine of recognizing that but
it doesn't add up to that much money
and I remember one time one of the
assistant managers showing me the books
for that place payroll for the entire
place was 20% of the gross 40% of the
gross was pure profit that's what we
call surplus value the the people who
own the means of production and hire
proletariat's to engage in wage labour
are using their labor say 8 hours a day
and they're paying them in in product in
money just this little portion over here
well they appropriate to themselves they
exploit them they appropriate to
themselves the lion's share even when
we're accounting for other things losses
you know cost of doing business
all these insurance all these other
things there's still this this profit
over here that they are then
appropriating now if this goes on and on
and on and on what happens those who
engage in wage labour don't make any
money they're stuck doing it the rest of
their lives it were in the absence of
something like a pension or social
security they'll do it till they die so
they or if they can't work and then
they'll they'll die because of that
because they have no money whereas the
rich the bourgeoisie the ones who own
the means of production they're
constantly making more and more and more
money so what does this mean in an
economy where that's happening there is
an equal there's a disequilibrium
comparison to the workers and the
workers actually are lower they have
lower they have less ability to buy
things because they're all within the
same marketplace so the lives of the
workers become worse and worse and worse
economically socially and whatever other
measure that you want to have and those
are those who have the wherewithal who
have what Marx and Engels call capital
who own the means of production become
better and better the the the
competition that that a capitalist
marketplace entails
also requires the impoverishment of the
worker you might say well no shouldn't
that keep costs down for the worker yeah
I said it does to a certain extent so
that's a benefit at the same time the
manufacturers are impelled to make
things as cheaply as possible and so
that means they want to pay as little as
possible because they want to be able to
compete against that other manufacturer
over there who might offer even even you
know cheaper product and then who is
going to get the lion's share of the
market share this is going to lead Marc
says to economic crises and these
economic crises are a major problem he
talks about these he talks about the
Perrigo epidemics of overproduction when
this happens everything every so often
society finds itself put back into a
state of momentary barbarism it appears
as if a famine a universal war of
devastation it cut off the supply of
every means of substance Industry and
Commerce seem to be destroying and why
here's the paradoxical thing because
there is too much civilization too much
means of substance too much industry too
much Commerce the productive force is at
the disposal of society no longer tend
to further the development of the
conditions of bourgeois property and
said they endanger it why because they
create a whole bunch of people who are
out of work and we're saying what what
am I going to do you know I don't have
anything I've got to feed myself and
after that some kids to feed as well and
that guy over there is doing pretty good
I'm gonna go beg him if he doesn't give
me something I'm gonna rob him and so
these economic crises produce some
incredible dis equilibria
they produce a lot of societal disorder
an instability
and that is the condition that the
proletariat lives in as Marx is going to
put it what's happening is the
proletariat it is having to is having
revealed to him or to her the actual
condition of human beings when we strip
away all of the finery all of the
ideology all of the mumbo-jumbo of
bourgeois morality he says that what
happens is there we go in the condition
of the proletariat those of the old
society at large are already virtually
swamped the proletariat is without
property he lacks any sort of ownership
his relation to his wife and children no
longer has anything in common with
bourgeois family relations as a matter
of fact you know we could switch it
around and say the relationship of a
proletariat has nothing in common the
relation of a proletariat to her husband
and children has nothing in common with
bourgeois family relations either
there's all this lip service that's made
to the importance of children and and
taking care of them and Parenthood and
motherhood but if you have to work you
have to work if Dave here isn't
available what do you do the proletariat
families bear the brunt of what's going
on in society law morality religion our
to the the proletariat so many bourgeois
prejudices behind which lurk and ambush
just as many bourgeois interests so
what's going on is is the the
bourgeoisie by impoverishing the
proletariat by placing in them in this
situation where it's getting worse and
worse and worse for them are in fact
producing their own gravediggers they're
producing people who have nothing to
lose by changing the order of society
nothing to lose by abolishing bourgeois
conceptions of property ownership and
production so we want to look at now is
the development of what we call class
justice the awareness of how things
actually are who you should be in
solidarity with who you should be
opposed to why you should value and what
you shouldn't and Mark says this has to
develop over time as well if there's a
historical process at first the
proletariat actually have the wrong
targets they have the wrong targets in
two different stages they attack the
instruments of production so he has
examples here about Weaver's who you
know woven by hand
seeing these looms and going and
attacking them and saying we're going to
destroy these the Luddites for example
we're previous were early destroyers of
machinery and he says they destroy
imported wares which compete with their
labor they smash to pieces machinery
they set up blazes they set factories of
lays what are they trying to do they're
trying to restore by force the vanished
status of the work person who was you
know not high up but at least had some
relative independence and status in the
Middle Ages but the Middle Ages are gone
that's not going to work
industrial society is what's what's here
to stay
meanwhile the bourgeoisie enlists the
proletariat in its own class struggles
so this is going to be very important
she says when the workers actually get
together to form bodies it's not the
consequence of their own active union
but the union of the bourgeoisie
which is trying to attain its own
political ends and it enlists the
workers it enlists the proletariat on
its side so the proletarians did not
fight their enemies he says but the
enemies of their enemies the remnants of
absolute monarchy the landowners the non
industrial bourgeoisie the petty
bourgeoisie they're they're all enemies
of the bourgeoisie who wants to
radicalize everything but then you know
keep things at that point and the
proletariat doesn't really realize that
they're they're not helping themselves
out by doing this they're actually May
things worse it's sort of like if you
were working at one of these big-box
stores and the the owners and the
management say we're under attack from
the local government we need all of you
to go in and protest outside City Hall
it might not be the end of the workers
interest to do that as a matter of fact
the workers might be getting screwed
maybe the best thing for the workers to
do would be to line up with City Hall
against their management and ownership
but they don't do that at first but in
the process of engaging in this fight
they begin to acquire some of the
intellectual tools they begin to acquire
some of the consciousness of their own
agency of their own ability to do
something and the next step is actual
development of their own unions they
begin to say forget it I don't need the
bourgeoisie let's get together ourselves
so he says with the development of
Industry the proletariat increases a
number but it becomes concentrated in
greater masses if strength grows and it
feels that strength it's becoming
conscious of its strength so growing
competition among the bourgeoisie brings
about commercial crises and the workers
then begin to say we need to do
something more rational the management
the owners they don't care about us when
things all go to hell they're fine and
they're their house on the hill we're
the ones who are suffering let's get
together and make sure that things
actually go the way that they're
supposed to go and so we see the
development of trade unions and then
fairly soon after that organization into
a political party or political parties
they're engaging in the political
process now and trying to have a say in
in their own destiny and how things go
now as this goes on there's going to be
some what we can call defect ations
from the bourgeoisie some of these are
involuntary these these processes of
industrial transformation are going to
take some of the people from the
bourgeoisie and turn them into losers
and the great game
and they were gonna fall from their high
status and say owners or manufacturers
down into the bourgeoisie same thing is
going to happen with some of the other
classes as well more and more people are
going to get added to it now those
people tend to be fairly well educated
and they also tend to have habits of
regarding themselves as possessing a
certain degree of dignity or agency and
they contribute they they when they
become part of the proletariat when they
become poor they can do an organizing
role and this actually has a very
important part in revolutionary
struggles he also talks about a small
section of the ruling class cuts itself
adrift and joins the revolutionary class
why do they do that
because they see that the revolutionary
class has as Marx and Engels who they're
saying the future in its hands they want
to line themselves up with where history
is going so some of the bourgeoisie
leave just just as much as in the French
Revolution one of the ways that that was
able to happen some of the aristocracy
joined the side of the bourgeoisie the
French Revolution was a bourgeois
rebellion by the way or a revolution now
where do we where do we go to he talks
about the the awareness and here's where
the class consciousness is ultimately
going the awareness of the illegitimate
see of the bourgeoisie the fact that the
bourgeoisie is as he says not fit to run
society why well because it's it's
generated a lot of wealth it's it's
actually created vast opportunities but
it's also made the condition for many
people worse and if we're going to say
who should run society how should
society structure which is a political
question as well as an economic question
the answer has got to be those who are
going to take care of us those who are
going to make conditions better the
bourgeoisie has shown that they can't
provide that according to Marx so he
says all other historical movement
we're movements of minorities this is
actually the self-conscious independent
movement of the immense majority in the
interest of the immense majority the
proletariat cannot raise itself cannot
raise itself up without the whole strand
of official society being knocked aside
being sprang into the air so what do we
need in this case and this is the the
Marxist response to this this is where
if you've been following along so far
you might say here's where I differ
because a lot of socialists actually
yeah is revolution that's the only thing
that is going to change these conditions
that's going to elevate mankind out of
this dog-eat-dog existence that the
bourgeois has led people into so he says
the bourgeois is unfit to rule because
it's incompetent to assure an existence
to its slave within his slavery it
cannot help letting him sink into such a
state it has to feed him instead of
being fed by him Society can no longer
live under this bourgeoisie in other
words its existence is no longer
compatible with society another thing
that you can say here is sort of society
humanity Marx and Engels think that
there's a lot to be said on the part of
the bourgeoisie for what they've done
they've opened up people's eyes they've
swept away to the previous inequalities
and you know traditional modes of
imposing power on people they manage to
create vast wealth but they haven't
delivered on what they want to do and so
now it's time for them to get out of the
way if they won't get out of the way
they have to be swept out of the way